yes
special meeting minutes of july 13
yep that
i i it was a
motion to approve both
you need to make sure the red light's on
uh good morning mr chairman my name is
grant nichols i'm the assistant director
of the new hampshire division of ports
and harbors
um
what does this
do
well um we we make this trip
once a year um it's uh this fifty
thousand dollars is used uh
for um for emergency repairs at our
facilities before the portsmouth fish
pier
uh rye harbor facility in the hampton
facility as everyone on the committee
knows we
we have pretty harsh weather conditions
in the state of new hampshire and it's a
little more
a little more harsh along the seacoast
you know with uh with wind water and
wave action
so our facilities uh they feel the brunt
of that and um
we prefer not to use this money in an
emergency capacity but um
on occasion you know we'll have things
that that break or fail
so that is that is what this fifty
thousand dollars is is set aside for um
there's a process that we go through we
uh
we actually have to have approval from
the peace development authority board of
directors before we expend the money um
but this
the nature of these failures at the uh
facilities are such that
the the repairs have to be made pretty
quickly
so
it just kind of expedites the process
questions from the committee
to
the division
representative excuse me senator reagan
uh senator reagan moos
uh approval of 22.014
seconded by
representative petrie
there any discussion on the motion to
approve 22-014
see none
all those in favor signify by saying aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved um hopefully gino is
just a routine
medical checkup okay the other day so
yeah every year i did get his email
saying he had a medical
appointment i was just worried that we
wouldn't see his smiling face
um thank you very much
um
we have several
informational items that were provided
um
are
there any questions for departments or
are anything on any of the informational
items that anybody wants to discuss
see none
our next meeting is scheduled for monday
may ah three of me
monday
november 28 2022
um
in lob room 201 203 at 10 15 a.m
so
that will be our last meeting for this
session of the general court
if
any of the agencies have anything they
need to get it in at that time because
it will probably be march before this
committee meets again
with the advent of the next session of
the general court with that i'll accept
the motion to adjourn
uh senator byrdsil
uh moves that we adjourn seconded by
senator daniels all those in favor
signify by saying aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and we
stand
uh adjourned until our next regularly
scheduled